I think we've just been through a real
hammering over the past ten months I
mean if you've still got your optimism
intact and believe me I do you've been
through the fire this has not been an
easy 10 months for the people of this
planet or the planet itself and so I
want to sort of reach back tonight and
invoke a bamming tradition get to the
heart of it and try to show how we can
bring this forward in our lives to
empower hope in the most darts of
situations and in fact to even make
these dark situations the raw material
of a clearer stronger hope than might
ordinarily be the case a few days ago I
was talking to a friend of mine and he
wanted to tell me the story of sitting
in the presence of a hundred and
four-year-old Vietnamese monk and the
guy had basically kept his mouth shut
the monk hadn't said much around the
monastery where he just sort of cleans
up but then he announced he wanted to
talk about meditation and he opened his
remarks by saying we are all luminous
beings why then do we not appear before
each other
radiant in our illumination and this is
the conundrum of life this is the
problem it was TS Eliot who said between
the idea and the reality between the
motion and the app Falls the shadow and
why is that as psychedelic people this
is the problem that we grapple with in
our own lives and when we look out at
the world you've heard me say many times
we have
the vision we have the money we have the
technology but why can we not then
appear before each other as radiantly
luminous beings and quite enough we
reclaim our planet from toxification
disease overpopulation bonehead politics
you know the list what the hang-up here
what is the problem why is perfection so
distant well what I've learned from lies
and vegetables travels and books can be
summed up in two Greek words it's the
central message of the philosopher
Heraclitus and he was always my favorite
philosopher but whenever I would read
about him he was called The Crying
philosopher and I had to live to be 44
years old to understand the poignancy a
paralyzes Messick he said in a nutshell
hunted ray all clothes all clothes
nothing lacks nothing is permanent and
this is the hardest message life has to
teach because what it says is your joy
is transient your anguish is transient
your fortune your home your dream your
moments of great ecstasy your moments of
great insight your moments of great
empowerment everything is flowing
through your hands at the moment that
you are aware of it
William Blake he in a way set this
engine going a couple of centuries ago
said mm-hmm what is the price of
experience is it bought for a song or
wisdom for a dance in the street no it
is bought with all that a man can his
wife his home his children now this is
not a pessimistic message and William
Blake was not a pessimistic guy he was
the same guy he told us that if we could
but cleanse the doors of perception we
would perceive the world as it is
infinite in a grain of sand how can we
take this poignant see this sense of
impermanence and weld it into something
which is paradoxically indestructible
and has meaning in our lives and gives
us not only the strength to carry on but
the power to be exemplars the power to
stand up before other people and let
them then feel the power of vision in
the paradox of permanence in the face of
the need for indestructibility it's
absolutely irrational to not be filled
with the fire of consuming hope our best
moments have always been when a tiny
thing tiller
another good alchemical word a tiny
spark of that alchemical completion
burns for a moment in our mind in our
life in our perception and we occupy a
special position
in regard to this millions thousands of
generations of human beings had come and
gone and could only glimpse this in the
ecstasy of eroticism and psychedelic
empowerment and ritual magic but we are
the last people beyond us lies the
mystery if we have but the courage to
move forward into that abyss to believe
that nature will reward the dreamer then
we can complete that wonderful Irish
toast which says may it be alive at the
end of the world because it's that close
it cannot wander much longer all of the
preconditions have been been met and the
Peacocks tail grows daily whiter and
more radiant and more brilliant as we
sense now breaking into our dreams
breaking into our waking lives the
presence of this attractor it has always
given Cathay meaning but we are the
privileged inheritors of that meaning
and we have been the privilege of
putting it all together in one piece and
standing ready at the end of history to
go into the mystery and be completed so
that's the end of my song
[Music]
you